Okay, so let's continue our journey
through transformers. We already
discussed the use of transformer in the
seek to seek model where we replace the
RNN encoder with the self attention
mechanism which we call transformer.
Here we want to see if such
representation learning can be used in a
maybe more familiar domain of vision and
image classification. something that we
almost solved using our CNN's and we
want to see if uh transformers can be as
useful as the proven CNN or
[clears throat] maybe they can beat
CNN's then we will talk about an
architecture that is known as vision
transformer within this comparison there
are some challenges within that that we
will talk about with some solutions okay
so like I said we replace RNN with
transformers and the main reason that we
did that it was because um RNN had this
sequential processing that led to slow
training and thus they could not be
scaled. They also had this vanishing
gradients that prevents us from going
for a very long sentence or text during
the encoding and decoding. We added
attention across attention more
specifically that allows the decoder to
attend to all of these hidden states in
the encoder. But still we are doing the
encoding with the recurrent neural
networks which is still a bottleneck.
Adopting a transformer architecture
basically dropping the RNN entirely led
to a fully parallel architecture which
is much faster and can be scaled while
using all of our GPUs and also having a
global context. really the the distance
between words or token didn't matter for
uh self attention. Every pair of tokens
could attend to each other. We discussed
the trans uh the design of transformers
where the residual uh connections uh
help the gradient flow and then we
discussed this machine translation
problem uh solved by transformer and how
it became the state-of-the-art. So now
the question is if transformers u beat
RNN's for sequence can they also beat
CNN's for images? Um well for images
like I said we we had a good run with
CNN's so let's see if the transformers
are up for this challenge. So back in
2020 CNN's were still the dominant par
paradigm for vision. We had very
efficient designs using ResNet and
efficient net. We had a lot of uh
excellent benchmarks like imageet and
other data sets that allowed the
community to do a lot of development and
advancement
uh and introducing different techniques
to make CNN's really work well. The
question is if we had more data can
CNN's um still improve is there maybe
that we can recast the question like
this does CNN's with their philosophy
their inductive bias have the
flexibility to continue improvement with
more data so then the experiment was
okay so machine translation solved by
transformers can we do the same for
images the idea is transformers are very
flexible so we don't need really do a
lot of modification. We just need to
find a way to represent the images as
input or tokenize them in a way that we
can feed it to the transformer and
that's it. The rest will be just waiting
for the result and the computation. If
you remember back when we were working
with MLPS, we flatten the image data
like a vector and here we are somehow
doing that again. So if we want to
compare that with what we did in text.
So in NLP we extract this word tokens
and we discuss that we have different
ways of doing this tokenization. Here in
computer vision and image data we are
working with patches within this images.
In the NLP we work with the encoder
transformer to find the representation
of the sentence. We do the same here
too. Output same. we have this token
embeddings that is the output of the
encoder transformer. We do the same and
we encode this patch embeddings. So in
the sik to seek uh architecture we we
did translation and we really decode to
another sequence but we could just use
the encoder part and do text
classification. Here we do the same and
we use the encoder to find this
representation of the image and send it
to a classifier head. So this is a
sketch of what I just described. So
instead of using the complete
transformer encoder decoder, we only
want to use the encoder. We get this
input tokens and we add another token
that attends to all of these input
tokens in the same self attention block.
And since CLS token or classification
token see all of these other tokens, we
can just use it as a output of the
encoder which will be a transformed
token and send it to the classification
head and get the logits. Okay. So
basically we are not doing any
translation. We just understand the
input token and do classification just
like what we did for image
classification using our CNN. So you
will see this classification token later
in other architectures when we work with
texts. But you could think of well what
if we don't have this and we just take
in the input token and transform them
and get the output tokens and then just
average them using some learnable fit
for our neural network to get the
average representation and then send it
to the classification. Well, the idea is
we are somehow doing that in the
transformer encoder. So, we send the CLS
embedding here and we are doing it in a
more flexible way that the simple
averaging cannot do it in a more
flexible way through this self attention
mechanism that the separated averaging
is unable to do. So, that's really the
idea of this CLS token. And you can also
think of we basically don't touch the
transformer encoder and the
classification head by just adding a
token here. So it's also more easy on
the pipelines that we already have. So
here is the vision transformer pipeline.
We divide the image into this similar
size patches and then we flatten them as
vectors and we feed them uh to the patch
embedding layer. So note that we have a
positional embedding here and again the
reason is uh self attention doesn't
really care about the order and we know
that approximity of this pixel values
really has meaning that was one of the
rules uh or induction biases that we
infused to our CNN. Now how to do this
positional embedding? We have different
options and we will talk about some of
them. Uh but the main point here is we
basically add this positional embedding
like a bias to our tokens and find this
more oriented uh tokens and send it to
the self attention mechanism which is
similar to what we had in the
transformer encoder and at the end we
get this transformed representation for
each one of these tokens and we only use
the CLS updated representation for a
classification. So some more details on
how to do this patching for an image of
heights and widths H and W. We divide it
into P by P non-over overlapping
patches. Which means we will have T
patches. For example, for an image of
224x
224 3 channel RGB, a 16x6 patch will
result into 196 patches. Note that we
have three channels. So each patch will
result in a vector of 768 values. This
is similar to convolution where we had
the kernel size and stride similar to
this patch patch size. So this means
basically the kernel is the patch and
they're non-over overlapping on the
positional embedding like I said self
attention is permutation invariant. So
we have to infuse some knowledge of the
spatial location of these patches and
this is how we do it. So after we
getting this values let's call them x
for each patch which proh is projected
into this vector embeddings and then we
add this the positional embedding into
each one of these embedded patches
including the cls. So you may think of
why we are learning the the position
again because like I said this is a
learnable like lookup table and why we
are wasting learning on something that
is already there. we have we can have
indexes indices for each patch. Firstly,
the amount of learning or the number of
parameters that we are spending on this
uh positional
uh learnable position embedding is
peanut really compared to the entire
parameter but also it's not really
restricted to just looking at the
surrounding patches anymore and it can
learn richer geometry than the cartisian
geometry. So basically it's more
flexible. That's what I'm trying to say.
Moreover, the uh authors of VIT paper
they showed that replacing the learnable
embedding with the indices of the
patches um really um doesn't give us any
gains and we are losing flexibility.
Another important uh distinction from
the original uh transformer is how where
to place the layer norm. And if you
remember the original transformer as the
norm after the residual here in the vit
and other modern architectures we have
the layer norm before the layer. So we
discussed that before that uh such a
pre-orm setup that does the
normalization before the addition of the
residual path makes it easier really for
the gradient flow and also during the
training. we really don't need to be
very careful at the beginning because of
that those issues. So we can push the
gas pedal and the training uh f sooner.
Okay. So uh well we had lengthy
discussion on why CNN
u brings this inductive biases and all
of those benefits of doing that. For
example, the translation invariance
looks at each uh looks for patterns no
matter where is that pattern, right? So
the same weights uh can be shared
regardless of where we are looking at.
And for a local feature only nearby
pixel really matter if there there's an
edge we really don't need to look
elsewhere there is an edge right. So
that means that we can use finite kernel
size and then the hierarchical receptive
field based on this small kernel size
will give us the bird eye at the end.
This leads to strong prior. So this
strong prior helps us to train this CNN
architectures using medium-sized data
sets while generalizable on unseen
images. But the question here is does
that inductive bias limits the capacity
of CNN's or basically creates a ceiling
on what CNN's can do? I mean yes it they
are very regularized uh because of that
and very efficient in terms of the
number of parameters but does that mean
that they are less expressive and we may
miss something in terms of the amount of
learning? So that's the hope that we can
fill in uh with transformers because
transformers are really don't they don't
have any of those biases. Uh there's no
locality bias because self attentions
look at all pairs. We are not enforce
enforcing translation invariance and we
let the position embedding to be
learned. So that means that the content
of the image is not really a
hierarchical reasoning of this spatial
proximities. For example, putting edges
together. It's something more than that.
So for example, an edge can be a
different edge when we are looking at a
somewhere else in the in the image which
is not next to that edge. So we can
interpret that edge differently because
of that this so this lack of um
geometric spatial proximity that we
enforce in CNN uh but not here in the
transformers allow the transformers to
learn something else that we could not
learn in CNN's okay so to summarize we
are doing a trade-off CNN's we have
strong handcrafted biases which led to
sample efficiency But there might be a
plateau in the performance in the vision
transformers. We have minimal biases
which requires much more training. So we
need more data. But they are
transformers and we know that
transformers are scalable. And now when
we give enough data to these
transformers, this more capacity can
lead for better learning. Okay. So let's
see the empirical evidence for this
hypothesis. So for that we go to the
original paper for visual transformer.
So here x-axis is basically the number
of JFT pre-training samples and JFT data
set from Google. So we look at the model
pre-trained by this many number of
samples. The y-axis is the accuracy of a
linear probe trained with five label
labeled examples per class on top of
this frozen pre-trend model. We see that
with small pre-training sets, resonance
are still better, but they plateau while
we give them more images. For example,
um from the 30 million to 100 million,
then we don't see any improvement for
the resonance. However, if when we
provide large training sets, the visual
transformers overtake CNN and they
continue improving. So the plateau may
never happen and that's the idea that we
will look at later. Here just to read
the image the rest of these curves we
only focus on this um light blue and the
the black ones but the rest uh here L
stands for large B for base. This uh
lowerase B is a base model with uh half
the hidden dimensions of the the
original one. The number 16s and 32 is
basically the the patch size and we see
the large visual transformer with a
patch size of 16 is surpassing the CNN
and continue improving. So this G gives
us a recipe. The modern machine learning
paradigm is pre-train on massive data
sets billions of examples and then
fine-tune on downstream tasks with much
less data. So the pre-training often is
done with much larger resources and
compute and the finetune can be done in
commodity computers. So in such regime
transformers really excels. We even have
um scale that we know how much it
improves. So we can even invest on it.
We know that there is not a plateau and
with the amount of resource that we are
willing to invest we will get this much
improvement and this result is really
across all modalities not just images or
text. So next we will talk about the
scaling laws and then uh much larger
pre-trained models in in natural
language and then we discuss this idea
of having these pre-trained models and
use them as foundation models that can
be fine-tuned for different tasks. But
before doing that let's go back to
visual transformer and discuss the the
major problems that it had in this small
medium data set regime. Like I said,
we're dealing with this lack of
inductive bias, which means that they
can overfeit very easily in such regimes
and they really need more data to be
able to shine. And the other problem is
we're dealing with u quadratic cost
complexity with this number of um
patches and we are not looking at u
different scales like for example
smaller to larger scale in a
pyramid-like scheme like CNN. We
basically look at every pair of hatches
at once. So the idea is well maybe we
can use some of the lessons that we
learned from the CNN trainings and at
the same time we can use this
transformer scalability. In other words,
can we inject some of these CNN priors
in different points of this vision
transformers? Well um I try to
categorize them in three different
categories. The first one u is basically
we look at this front ending the feed to
the transformers which basically we give
a uh we do some pre-processing of the
data using CNN stems and then feed that
features learned by CNN CNN to the
transformer. The other idea is to use
this hierarchical way of learning in CNN
uh but use that within transformer
architectures. And then then the other
idea is to bring a CNN that can teach
our transformer. So at some point the
student can be better than the teacher
and that's the distillation idea. So
this is the data efficient um
transformers. So really there was
another idea here that basically we can
think of expanding or inflating the the
data by different augmentations and this
way we basically somehow artificially
increase the number of data points and
let the transformer believe that there
are more data. So this way transformers
start improving.
So it's a combination of these two which
somehow implicitly bring the CNN into
the equation. The other two we really
bring the CNN idea explicitly into the
equation. For example, in this hybrid
VIT we have a CNN at the front of the
transformer. But in the third one we let
a CNN to guide our transformer. So we
will focus on the third one because of
its flexibility.
Basically we still have a transformer
and we are not really limiting its
architecture. We just train it using a
CNN. So we are not losing any of that
those flexibility and scalability
properties and we keep the transformer
pure. So the idea is coming from this
paper by to run it all from Surbon and
the goal was to make VIT competitive on
a small scale data set an imageet more
specifically
like I said the insight is let's use a
CNN and back then they used this
uh CNN that was the state-of-the-art as
a teacher that transfer its knowledge
through this distillation process during
training like I said they also consider
augmentation, regularization
and then some other techniques along the
way. But really the main idea here that
I want to talk about is this
distillation idea because somehow we
will talk about variance of this even in
the language models. So here they add a
distillation token just like the
classification token that learns from
the CNN teachers. the CNN teachers
predictions and softly imports this
prior the teacher has into the training.
So here is a schematic from the paper.
You see the class token and the
dissolation token and here we have two
laws. One loss is basically looking at
the transformed class token and do the
classification based on the real data
and the other loss is to predict the
prediction of the teacher and once we
deploy the model we only look at the
prediction the real prediction of the
model
but this will guide this other transform
token. So you may think oh well how can
the network can be better than the
teacher? Well it's just like how you
guys will be better than me. You will
see other things and you will decide for
yourself. Right? This is no enforcement.
This is just a loss and a tradeoff that
the model will do and eventually it is
exposed to the real data and real labels
and will learn what it can learn from
the both classes. So this is a maybe a
zoom in into the training where we get
the patches and then we do the embedding
along with the CLS and this tokens and
then the same transformer encoder. We
are not touching this and we only use
two of the transform tokens out of the
transformer and one will be fed to the
distillation head and one to the
classification head. The distillation
head gets the labels from a frozen CNN
teacher. The classification head gets
the label from the data. Okay. So let's
uh zoom into this last terms and how
they are handled in this uh setup
as this is a good exposure to knowledge
distillation. um a technique that
basically a smaller student network
learns to mimic a larger or better
teacher model here CNN and the student
is the transformer. Okay, so to do that
let's look at the paper. So here we only
look at the class token. There's not yet
a distillation token. And if we want to
do the distillation only with the class
token, first we compare the the
prediction of the class token which is
the soft max with the true ground truth
label using a cross entropy loss and
also we add a kale divergence that
basically enforce the network to learn
the same distribution for the logits as
the teacher. Okay. So this is kind of
soft label distillation meaning that we
learn the distribution
the prediction
um so we learn the distribution of the
uh the prediction of the teacher here.
So this is a soft distillation but the
authors uh discuss this hard label
distillation meaning that we want to
look at the prediction of the teacher as
if that's the a label and in that case
we go to the hard distillation which we
want to not only predict the ground
truth we also want to predict the the
best guess of the teacher not the
distribution of the guesses. And here is
where the authors are discussing this
new token, the distillation token to
basically separate the two losses using
two heads. So using the distillation
token
here from the distillation head and
using the class token here in the class
class head and they showed that uh this
way the network actually learns more
uh than no distillation. And also they
showed that a CNN teacher works better
than a VIT teacher. Although the VIT
teacher does a better job by itself, but
it's not a better teacher for our
architecture. And the reason is
basically CNN teacher brings something
that is different. It's a different
inductive bias that the transformer
doesn't have. So the student while
remaining flexible also learns what the
teacher knows. So that's somehow
uh reinforcing the assumption that
diversity helps as that uh leads to a
richer learning signal. So the teacher
model is only active during the training
and the model learns to use both tokens
effectively and during the inference of
course we don't need the teacher anymore
and we can [clears throat] also skip the
distillation head. Uh but the authors
suggest to keep it and make an average
of the two to basically do this kind of
consensus
uh to achieve a better performance. So
this is the first figure of the same
paper uh where they showed the distilled
version of the network works better than
the comparable normal network with
similar um resources. So here that is
efficient net and we al already
discussed that in the previous lectures
and we see that with the same amount of
latency or compute during the inference
the distilled uh model works the best.
Note that this is the the same model
without distillation. So we will see
knowledge distillation later but note
that here we basically transfer these
biases across this architectures
and instead of a mirror compression we
instead bring an efficient learning that
the smaller model is not really copying
the teacher but it's learning from the
teacher and eventually becomes better.
So the teacher signal is not really
replacing the ground truth.